In this video you’ll see 5 different party
pleasers done with dry ice.
#5. Take a flaming candle, and place it down
into a container like a bowl or a glass. Carefully
pour some crushed dry-ice, down around the
base of the candle. And within just a few
seconds, you'll notice the flame goes out,
and the gas turns completely invisible. Now
challenge one of your friends to try and re-light
the candle inside the glass. They won't be
able to do it and they'll have no idea why.
Even after multiple attempts, the flame goes
out every time.
#4. For this trick, find a block of dry-ice,
and break it into pieces the size of small
rocks. Carefully place one or two of the pieces
inside of a balloon, and tie it off. You'll
notice the balloon begins to inflate all by
itself. Now try doing this with a bunch of
other balloons and throw them all into a basket.
Over the course of about 25 minutes, the balloons
will keep growing, until you've got a basket
overflowing.
#3. Start this prank by opening up a Ziploc
bag and adding a few chunks of dry ice, followed
by a little bit of warm water. Now seal the
bag so it's completely air-tight, and find
a place to hide it. After a minute or two,
the bag will be completely pressurized and
ready to explode. Who could you scare with
this?
#2. For this party trick, take a large metal
spoon and press it down into a block of dry-ice.
It lets out an awful squeal, and people will
beg you to stop. You can make a quarter scream
the same way. Just lay it flat on the ice,
and press down into it. For a bonus trick
try sticking the quarter in sideways, it’ll
start shaking uncontrollably.
#1. For this last trick, add some crushed
dry ice into a large clear bowl. At this point,
try blowing the biggest bubble you can, and
drop it right into the center. Instead of
popping on the bottom, it levitates around
in mid-air, and will make your friends wonder,
"what kind of sorcery is this?"
Well now you know a few tricks, and pranks
with dry ice, that are super cool, and easy
to do. If you liked this project, perhaps
you'll like some of my others. Check them
out at www.thekingofrandom.com